all right well there's a legion stadium
and with sherry off today your most
accurate weather now forecast begins
with this look at the stadium it'll be
busy with football players but
unfortunately no fans come sunday night
but for right now
the official temperature at mccarran is
64. it's nice out there's no denying
that but
it is still warmer than we should be in
the middle of october
down to 60 right now for alliante same
thing up in centennial hills one more
in mountains edge down in the south
seven hills and anthem you're at 62.
it's beautiful for taking a walk taking
a jog walking the dog or whatever but
there are going to be big time changes
coming later in the week first it's
going to be
very very windy which will be tough
getting around in and then big time
cooler temperatures getting us closer to
where we'd normally be for this time of
year
so death valley is below 70 mid 50s for
sandy valley and of course
way up in ely it is below freezing now
yesterday we topped it out at 90 that's
we're expecting to do today that's more
than 10
degrees above normal our current
temperature is the low so far this
morning there's the record high
of 95. so this is the big weather
changer getting
ready to march closer to the shore it's
a very powerful area of low pressure
very strong winds much cooler
temperatures we talked about the
possibility some rain that does not
appear to be the case
so here's some snow over montana and
dakotas
but there was also snow north of
minneapolis yesterday
a ski area actually opened just north of
minneapolis
and plenty of folks came on out there
looked like slushy
wet heavy snow but skiing in
october in minnesota well let's get you
on back home
boy i bet you the las vegas ski and
snowboarders ordered up at lee canyon
would love to get some of that they're
still pushing for a late after
thanksgiving december opening
90 for your high today 92 tomorrow the
winds begin on thursday gusts maybe to
40 miles an hour we're anticipating the
likelihood of wind advisories for friday
none have been issued but behind that
much cooler weather
dropping down to 74 for sunday maybe
only 70 for monday